[Music]
your name is rip hunter you fly the
Waverider is a time pit there's no such
thing as rip hunter and there's no such
thing as a Timeship
captain Holmes's has been reprogrammed
for the new identity
breezes scrambled by the pieces to bring
back
we are you I am cookies my name is self
who do we kill first ha DC's legends of
tomorrow whole new episodes return on a
new night Tuesday January 24th on a CW
hey youtubers is Charlie new legends of
tomorrow footage we got to talk about
future flash war reverse flash versus
Barry spear of destiny so let's go there
is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a flash
related comment on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so that you don't miss anything
so there's a whole bunch of stuff going
on here we actually have some of the
plotline from the flash that's spilling
over so I'll try to explain everything
number six the legend since a massive
time quake in the 60s because of
something that the Legion of Doom is
doing they come back and they have this
scene here where they find rip hunter
but surprise surprise
he doesn't know anything about what's
going on and he has this crazy American
accent I totally love this and then you
sort of have that funny moment where
he's like there's no such thing as time
travel time shifts and then you get the
reveal of the Timeship it actually looks
like he was getting ready to jump off
the top of that parking garage so the
description reads is that he's like this
film student so they're being really
funny about it
so everything's gone crazy but now rip
hunter is a big part of the story again
we kind of got teasers for him earlier
in the season you know almost forgot
it's moving to Tuesday night so that's
going to cause like a big shift in my
schedule the way I post videos between
the flash and legends of tomorrow and
arrow so I'll try to explain what's
going on next week there'll be some more
footage so don't worry I'll remind
everyone what the video schedule is
going to be number 5 though the reasons
that he's back is because of the spear
of destiny plot so when he knew at the
beginning of the series the things were
going bad the ship was going down he set
this plan in motion
and then hid himself in time like
everybody thought that he was dead the
Justice Society had no idea what was
going on but because of the time drift
he started to forget who he was
the Legion finds him and it seems like
they have some footage here as they
include that was from the other trailer
where the reverse-flash is interrogating
him this looks like the scene where they
messed with his mind or give him a new
identity the reverse-flash has all the
coolest toys this season toys for
becoming other people toys for getting
information out of people so that's
probably just the beginning but the
whole reason for this is that they think
that rip hunter has the spear of destiny
or knows where it is so that's why the
légion wants them in they're also
teasing a little bit of the
reverse-flash versus the legion of doom
which I'll talk about in a second but
it's basically evil slowly turning on
itself and I'm really happy about this
because it says a lot about the reverse
flashes plan in his character so number
4 the spear of destiny you may remember
the spear from the Constantine movie
that was like a big MacGuffin of that
movie you know you attain it you gain
the power of a god you could pretty much
do almost anything you want the
reverse-flash explains to the Legion of
Doom that they can use it to rewrite
reality so berry can change reality by
going back changing the past the best
way to explain it is that you have to
imagine stuff like flashpoint is
changing reality using big broad strokes
like you change something something
stays the same
using the spear of destiny is like
rewriting reality with a fine tip 10 you
can make really minor edits without
affecting the timeline in a way that
will bring the time race in the black
flash so a lot of you do ask how come
the reverse flash is able to time travel
so much without having to worry about
the time race he's just a lot smarter
about the way he does it
he has very special plans for the spear
of destiny the Legion of Doom all have
different reasons for wanting it they
all have different things that they want
to change about reality the
reverse-flash only cares about getting
rid of Barry Allen it's so beautiful
very simple idea but very hard in
practice so I'll probably need to do a
different video that will explain that
plan because you'll slowly learn more
about it through the rest of the season
but there are just a lot of Hoops that
he has to jump through in order to get
rid of Barry without also getting rid of
himself because his destiny is so tied
to Barry's becoming the flash so it gets
a little crazy but this is also where we
start looping back in the plotline on
the flash TV show number 3 future flash
war so on the flash right now we got
this tease that something crazy is going
to happen with savat are he's going to
kill iris Barry is going to do anything
he can to try and stop that meaning that
the message that they got from future
Barry from future flash on legends of
tomorrow is from a timeline where
nothing changed is like just the regular
future for what
happening on the flash right now but
something terrible happens berries like
you can't trust me you can't trust
anyone everything has gone to hell so
the flash TV show is all about changing
that future so you have to imagine that
right now Berry is on a course to become
like the blue Future flash in this sort
of post-apocalyptic wasteland so there's
this big war with Savitt our that he's
teasing is coming Barry has become the
future flash it's really like the worst
possible scenario so what does that have
to do with the reverse flash in the
spear of destiny
well the reverse flash has a version of
Gideon so he has actually been
monitoring all the things that Barry has
been doing when he drops Barry off in
the beginning of season 3 after he's
killed his mother again the reverse
flash gives him that evil laugh and says
oh you'll find out so he knows exactly
what's been happening with savat are in
all this stuff he just kind of been
trying to avoid it he doesn't want to
draw too much attention to himself
the other big thing this season number 2
the reverse-flash first a legion of doom
so while he's been trying to stay off of
sabotage radar and watch barry try to
spin his wheels trying to save iris he's
also been trying to play the Legion of
Doom so I was so happy when the
producers talked about tension within
the league about how they'd start
fighting each other so they're being
very true to eobard thawne in the comics
he's not somebody that has friends he's
not someone that makes alliances he
works with other people really most of
his relationships are just him moving
pawns around on a chess board like he
wants something he knows he needs a
couple other people to get it so that's
what the Legion is to him just a couple
of chess pieces to move around to get
him the spear so that he can get rid of
Barry the problem with that is that
Malcolm Merlyn and damian darhk-- are
both really big buildings in their own
right they're not dumb they figure this
out so part of the fun of the season is
sort of watching them unravel but here's
the main reason why legends season two
has been so much better than season one
number one it's because it's more of a
villain story it's like evil Goonies
treasure hunt the Legion of Doom is on a
treasure hunt to find the spear of
destiny
meaning that they will probably hold it
in their hand before it gets ripped out
somehow so evil always
turns on itself but then it all blows up
in their faces in the best possible way
it is my sincere hope the season 3 they
bring back the reverse-flash and heat
reforms the Legion of Doom offering
membership to black siren I feel like
she'd be a really great addition to that
evil team up because the villains on
this show are so much more important
than the heroes so as long as I got some
solid villains next season I feel like
it'll be great so there are a couple
really big concepts that I was talking
about here like future flash war very
becoming the future flash of the comics
on the TV show because he's trying to
save iris so if there are any special
flash videos that you want me to do to
explain concepts or storylines just let
me know in the comments congratulations
to the latest flash ring giveaway winner
Larry
Irby just private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video I'll just
announce the winner the next time I post
a DC video there's a whole bunch of
awesome stuff that I'll be posting this
weekend Star Wars Episode 8 some new
Legion some new Logan The Wolverine
movie and then some Game of Thrones
they'll be plenty more stuff so just
post updates as I post new videos while
you guys wait for there's a post you can
click here for Justice League Green
Lantern and you can click here for
marvel defenders thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight